Merry Christmas everybody welcome to the
last show before Christmas the last show
before the end of the year in fact so
there was a debate last night there was
a debate last night and that's the end
of my analysis on that subject so moving
on we'll talk about JK Rowling and left
isms increasing plunge into the realm of
being a superstitious cult rather than a
political ideology many examples could
be presented of course to prove that
point but this week's controversy
quote-unquote controversy surrounding JK
Rowling I think should suffice so for a
little bit of background there's this a
woman named Maya for stater and she's a
researcher of the United Kingdom who
recently lost her job for stating the
scientific and indisputable fact that
men cannot turn into women that's what
she said men cannot turn into women and
she before stater lost their job she
wants a court to win her job back but an
employment judge ruled against her this
week and said that for stators belief in
biological science is quote not worthy
of respect in a democratic society
actually let me quote from this judge a
little bit more at length because I
think you need to hear this this is
Judge James Taylor no relation I assume
he says if a person has transitioned
from male to female and has a gender
recognition certificate more on that in
a second that person is legally a woman
that is not something misses a Miss for
stater is entitled to ignore Ms for
stators position is that even if a trans
woman has a GRC she cannot honestly
describe herself as a woman that belief
is not worthy of respect in a democratic
society even paying due regards is still
Judge to the qualified right to freedom
of expression people cannot expect to be
protected if their core belief involves
violating other's dignity and creating
an intimidating hostile degrading
humiliating or infant offensive
environment for them I mean this is this
is a shocking and let's not be so jaded
by the left's insanity that we don't
appreciate how extra insane
is first of all you have the gender
recognition certificate I went to the
website the government website that
where you go if you want to get a gender
recognition certificate so if you want
to give your gender recognized in the UK
go to this website this is how they
describe the process of getting a gender
recognition certificate it says apply to
get to the gender recognition panel the
gender recognition panel for a gender
recognition certificate no by the way
I'm not reading something from a
dystopian fiction novel this is real
this is an actual thing okay apply to
the gender recognition panel for a
gender recognition certificate if you
want your acquired gender to be legally
recognized in the UK there are three
different ways to get a certificate
which one you use depends on your
situation here's the standard route
apply by the standard route if all of
the following are true you're 18 or over
you've been diagnosed with gender
dysphoria you've lived in your acquired
gender for at least two years and you
intend to live in your required gender
for the rest of your life okay that's
how you get a certificate now lived in
your acquired gender lived in acquired
gender what the hell does any of that
mean could anyone give me I don't know
three sentences explaining exactly what
that means how do you live in a gender
how do you live in a gender and how do
you acquire one and from where do you
acquire it just just think of how this
would sound in normal conversation oh I
acquired my male gender when I was 22
yeah I've been living in it for ten
years so not bad maybe a little problem
with the transmission I might have to
take it back to the dealership again
where are you acquiring this gender from
and how do you acquire it and what does
that mean to acquire it and living
energetic
this this is this part of the
superstition of the modern left what
they have created is the weirdest kind
of dualism that the world has ever seen
where they they're sort of separating
the person where you as a you you as a
person you are this kind of genderless
amorphous entity sort of floating around
and then your gender is something that
you select out of the ether and put on
like a sweater or get inside like a car
and just drive it around that's the way
they're presenting how the this works
and it it's it's oh the only thing you
can call that is religious doctrine it's
certainly not science and it makes no
logical sense and what is the judge
saying is he saying but the government's
decision to recognize your acquired
gender whatever that means magically
makes you into that Jenner turns you
into that gender because for stators
point about was was was not just about
the government's recognition the for
stators point was about what a person
actually is she was saying that a
biological male can't actually turn into
a woman so if this judge is disagreeing
he must be saying that a man who gets
this certificate is actually now a woman
that again is a supernatural claim that
is religious dogma this is like this is
like a perverse version of
transubstantiation or something instead
of the Eucharist turning into the body
and blood of Christ this is a man
supernaturally transforming into a woman
by the in cart by the incantation of a
government bureaucrat that's that's what
they're saying in fact here's one of
them just so we understand the context
here here's one of four Staters toy
tweets specifically here's what she said
I share the concerns of at fair play
women that radically expanding the legal
definition of women so that it can
include both males and females makes a
meaningless concept and will undermine
women's rights and protections for
vulnerable when
girls that's what she said and keep in
mind this judge didn't just say that she
was wrong in this blatantly obvious
assertion on her part the judge said
that there's it's it's it's so wrong it
is so vile so disgusting so horrible
that there's no place for it in society
but can anyone respond to the point she
made can any of the superstitious
cultists who believe in the fluidity of
gender actually respond to the point
that she made the point she's making is
that if yes if you expand this if you
expand woman to include males then the
word woman doesn't mean anything anymore
what does it mean now we'll get back to
that in a second as well he also ruled
that her views on biology do not have
the protected characteristic of
philosophical belief and on that point I
think he's actually correct because it's
not a philosophical belief that men
can't transition into women that's not a
philosophical belief that is a
scientific fact but a fact that these
days just cannot be stated publicly
without being punished so here's where
JK Rowling comes in and and this is
where she gets in line for cancellation
the author came to for stators defense
but did so in the mildest and most
leftist friendly way possible or so so
she thought so she wrote on twitter
Rowling did dress however you please
call yourself whatever you like sleep
with any consenting adult who will have
you live your best life and peace and
security but force women out of their
jobs for stating that sex is real
question mark and then hashtag I stand
with Maya that was it that's what she
said rallying here she affirms the
relativistic libertine position on every
point except she is not willing to
profess biological sex as a figment of
our imagination so simply for suggesting
that sex exists Rowling has found
herself in the middle of a leftist
firestorm and you've got thousands of
these science hating lunatics
we're calling her bigoted and
transphobic and on and on and on all
because she relayed a fact in
indisputable facts by the way there been
a lot of comments to Rowling a lot of
the responses would be hilarious if you
didn't consider the fact that this is
that these people exist in the millions
out there people that are this insane
but here's what one example there's a
lot of comments like this this one is
from Shamir Sahni on twitter it's got a
blue check so you know that his opinion
matters he says as a gay man that found
safety in Hogwarts throughout my
childhood
knowing that trans people wouldn't be
able to have that safety breaks my heart
there was again there's a lot of that
kind of stuff a lot of people
heartbroken to discover that trans
people aren't welcome at Hogwarts which
is a school for wizards and which by the
way doesn't exist and I would make fun
of them I guess I know a little bit how
they feel because I'll never forget when
I first discovered that Batman won't let
me into the Batcave very difficult to
deal with it crushed me but hey at least
we can all go to the Shire and hang out
with Bilbo Baggins
we still have that at least now you
could argue that that JK Rowling
deserves to be eaten by the alligator
she's been feeding all these years she's
a leftist herself she's been she's been
encouraging and and jumping in with the
pitch to leftist Pitchfork mob she's
done that many times and so maybe this
this she has all this coming and and and
probably she does but it is worth
highlighting her plight I think because
it underscores the point that I made at
the top which is that leftist gender
theory is a superstition and leftism is
a cult and I have no doubt that
certainly anthropologists of the future
when they're sifting through the
wreckage of our once great civilization
that is the conclusion they will come to
you know when they're going through and
discovering things like oh wow those
ancient people in 2019 thought that they
could literally change boys into girls
the only
they come to is that this is that this
this was some sort of insane
supernatural cult that grabbed hold of
American society and that's exactly what
happened now on a related note and
inspired by the the latest bit of
madness that we've been talking about
III I would like to repeat again a
challenge I've made to the left several
times and I wrote a piece yesterday
reiterating this challenge I put it up
on Twitter only now I'm gonna I'm gonna
up the ante a little bit as I announced
on Twitter yesterday I will this this is
my offer okay I will give and I'm dead
serious about this I will give a hundred
dollars not saying it's a ton of money
but hey it's it this is a hundred bucks
I'm willing to give somebody for really
nothing for no effort I mean why would
you take it here's all you have to do
for 100 bucks and I'll so then I'll
venmo it to you I'll pay pal whatever
you want to do I will give a hundred
dollars to the first leftist who can
provide me with a coherent definition of
the word woman that permits biological
males to be included yet still maintains
womanhood as a distinguishable and
objective category hundred bucks okay
around the holidays you could use 100
bucks could you now it's it is my
contention that this simple question as
I have said many times and I'll keep
going back to it over and over over
again but this simple question what is a
woman I believe completely dismantles
left-wing gender theory in its entirety
I claim that everything the left says
about gender can be discredited just by
posing this question all you have to say
is what is a woman and you win the
argument because after all a statement
like I identify as a woman can have no
meaning if the word woman has no meaning
and certainly if there's no difference
between women and men then for a man to
identify as a woman is
he might as well identify as a man when
he identifies his woman he's identifying
as a man and when he identifies as a man
he's identified as a woman so the whole
thing is redundant and pointless in fact
all statements all statements that
anyone has ever made about women become
incoherent if we don't have a working
definition of the term itself this is
not a trick question this is not a
gotcha moment this is a very fair very
basic question you are using the word
woman not just using the word but you
are making an extraordinary claim about
the nature of womanhood by saying that
this biological male with a function
with functioning male reproductive
organs can be a woman I think it's how
else could I possibly respond to that
but by asking what do you mean by woman
what do you mean by that that's all I
want to know now the problem for the
left is that they need the word woman to
mean something in order for feminist and
LGBTQ rhetoric to have to have any
revelant relevance whatsoever but any
attempt to define the word woman must
result automatically in the exclusion of
biological males there simply is no
available definition of woman that
legitimizes transgenderism if it means
anything for a woman to be a woman then
it cannot mean anything when a man says
that he is one so here's here's this is
this is the what I'm getting at I think
this is so important this stuff about
transgenderism it's it's not just
scientifically invalid it is
scientifically invalid but it's more
than that it is logically invalid it is
illogical which is very important
because it's not just that the left is
promoting a crazy new scientific theory
it's that they're making a claim that is
logically incoherent and thus
dismissible out of hand what they're
saying is the equivalent of claiming
that a circle has four sides that's
that's that's not a there's nothing
to even talk about that is that is just
nonsense that cannot be true
even if you even if you had supernatural
powers God Himself could not make it so
that a circle has four four sides
because it's illogical it doesn't mean
anything and that's what I'm saying with
with these claims it's forget about the
science for a second it is simply
illogical but you know if I'm wrong then
proof of that I'm wrong just give me a
definition that's all just a definition
I'll give you a hundred bucks you got
nothing to lose
so far no one's been willing to do it or
able to do it and that's what's so
amazing about this is that the left's
gender theories transgender ideology and
all that it is it is absolutely
indefensible they can't defend it
they can't even begin to defend it they
can't even define the words they're
using the most basic follow-up question
to their claim they can't answer whether
this biological male is a woman what do
you mean that's it what you're saying
what do you mean they can't answer that
question you hadn't when you just ask
for a clarify that but you've you've
already won they're Hardy defeated they
can't even go that far it's incredible
and that's why you know my experience
and I as you know I've talked about this
many times
and I've had many debates about it many
arguments and in my stand this is not a
straw man I have honestly in my life of
talking about this I have only ever
heard ever two defenses of this of the
of transgender ideology that you know
the left gender theory generally I've
only ever heard two defenses of it
that's it I'll tell you what those two
defenses are these are the only ones I
have ever heard aside from the most
common one is just screaming at me and
calling
bigot but the only actual sort of
attempts at a defense I've ever heard
are one what about intersex people and -
this doesn't affect you why you care
those are the only responses those are
the only defenses I have never heard
anything else aside from those two
intersex and how does it affect you so
let me let me just very quickly deal
with those because I know even you know
that's the responses I'm going to get to
this first of all with with intersex
people this is a response an argument
that is both incorrect and completely
irrelevant incorrect and irrelevant why
is it irrelevant well because when we
talk about this we're talking about
transgender people transgender people
are biological in biological males who
identify as women or biological females
who identify as males that's what it
means that's what a transgender person
is so the existence of intersex people
does nothing whatsoever to validate the
claims of a transgender person it is it
two different categories so it's
completely irrelevant so when I say that
you know if you're a biological male
you're a man and that's it how does it
validate the claims of a biological male
that he's actually a woman when he
points to someone else who is allegedly
intersex and has ambiguous genitalia
okay that's someone else that's not you
though what so if we if we were just
talking about intersex people then we
would be talking about intersex people
but we're not we're talking about trans
people and that's a completely separate
category so it's irrelevant completely
irrelevant this would be like if
somebody said if someone made a claim
and said I have three arms okay what if
I what if I right now claim that I have
three arms okay well I think you could
look and see that I don't really have
three arms I only have two
but then what if I said oh yeah well
what about that person over there he has
three arms and then I could present you
with someone with three arms even if I
could do that that doesn't mean that I
have three arms that doesn't validate my
claim to having three harms because
someone else does obviously but so
that's why it's irrelevant why is it
incorrect well it's incorrect because
actually sex is still binary sex is a
biological sex is a binary proposition
intersex people are not an exception to
that they do not represent some third
biological sex they don't represent an
in-between state they don't destroy the
binary at all again even if they did
that does absolutely nothing whatsoever
to validate the claims of transgender
people but it but it's not even sure
they don't an intersex person suffers
from a deformity and illness you know
genetic mutation and what that means is
that their biological sex is harder to
discern because it's not so immediately
obvious because of their physical you
know mutant genetic mutation that
doesn't mean they don't have a
biological sex it just makes it a little
bit harder to tell that's it
just like you take someone let's take
somebody with one arm there are people
born with one arm okay that doesn't that
doesn't mean that it's it's no longer
valid to say human beings have two arms
it is a valid statement to say human
beings have two arms they do okay just
like you could say spiders have eight
legs we could say that if you present me
someone with born with one arm well I
know automatically that this is somebody
with a genetic mutation or some other
something went wrong and if we're to
look at that person and you know and and
and do a medical check-up and all that
and we'll discover that sure enough
something went wrong so this is not a
new type of person who undermines the
the the statement that people have
Torme's this is just someone who was
supposed to have two arms but something
went wrong and
right or left arm just didn't show up
and so it's the same thing with intersex
people this is something went wrong it
doesn't you know we say the exception
proves the rule that's the exception
that proves the rule because when you
see an intersex person you automatically
know there's some sort of genetic
problem here there's some sort of
physical problem and and sure enough and
then the other claim is how does it
affect you again irrelevant and and
incorrect so both of both of these
responses are irrelevant and incorrect
you know it doesn't affect me that does
nothing to to legitimize the fact that
the claims of fact that are being made
so if you you know if we're having an
argument about what is the capital of
Maryland and you're saying it's
Baltimore and I'm correctly pointing out
that it's Annapolis and then I pull out
a map and show you sure enough it's an
Annapolis you can't say well how does it
affect you that I'm saying Baltimore's
the capital man it might not affect me
but you're still wrong we're not talking
about how the argument is not how am i
affected by your claim about the capital
of Maryland the argument is what is the
capital of Maryland and you're wrong so
affect me who cares what difference does
that make the argument here is about the
nature of biological sex and gender what
are the facts of the case it's not about
who's affected by it so that's why it's
irrelevant but it's also incorrect
because if we were having an argument
say I think this is more analogous if we
were having an argument about basic
arithmetic and you were claiming that 2
plus 2 equals 7 and and I'm pointing out
that no 2 plus 2 equals 4 and then I
pull out 4 apples and I demonstrate it
for you or I get out of calculator and I
show you and then you say how does it
affect you it doesn't affect you that
I'm saying 2 plus 2 equals 7 well
irrelevant okay you're still wrong I'm
right but it really would affect me if
you then turn around and organize a
nationwide campaign to convince
everybody that 2+2 equals 7 and to
punish those who claim that two plus two
equals four
and to indoctrinate our kids into the
belief that 2+2 equals 7 when you start
doing that it very much affects me
because now you're trying to reorganize
society around a delusion you're trying
to dismantle arithmetic which is a
pretty useful thing you're trying to get
rid of that and destroy it and
reorganize society around this
delusional claim that you're making
does it affect me yeah yes it does
obviously it's the same thing here and
this is it is it is directly analogous
really trying to deny the biological
realities of men and women is just as
crazy as denying that two plus two
equals four and trying to reorganize
society around the delusional
superstitious claim that biological
males with functioning male reproductive
organs can be women is just as damaging
to society as trying to dismantle basic
arithmetic you know this holiday season
do your friends a family is solid by
giving them a daily wired gift
membership and the good news for you
until January first you got to get a few
more days all inside or plus gift
memberships we 25% off that means your
loved ones will get all the fantastic
perks plus the majestic beautiful
glorious leftist tiers tumblr and you'll
get the savings that's 25 percent off
all insider plus gift memberships in
this holiday season go to daily wire.com
slash gift to get your twenty five
percent off again that's daily wire.com
slash gift to get your twenty five
percent off give them a gift that
they'll thank you for all year long
here's something the New York Post
headline says flirting with coworkers
helps reduce stress according to new
study flirting with coworkers substitute
stress and you know I know that sounds
crazy and people were reacting to that
online saying us is nuts but there's a
lot of truth to it I think because think
about it if you get fired for sexual
harassment
it will really reduce the stress of
having to get up early for work so in a
way I can see
how that would how that would work all
right a couple other stories to hit on
before we we read some emails and called
a year as the daily wire reports after
Hallmark Channel pledged its allegiance
to GLAAD the Gay and Lesbian Alliance
Against Defamation in the wake of its
decision to pull an ad that featured two
lesbians kissing the site indieWIRE has
now called upon the channel to make its
first LGBT movie Jude dry writing for
indieWIRE says if hallmark really wants
to make an impact and show the LGBTQ
community its commitment to inclusive
inclusive inclusivity it should
greenlight an LGBTQ script ASAP Jude
rise call echoed that of GLAAD president
Sarah Kate Ellis who said that LGBTQ
people are are and will continue to be a
part of advertisements and family
programming and that will never change
according to DRI a more inclusive
Hallmark Channel would be like the
company's greeting card wing which
already features a robust offering of
LGBTQ friendly holiday cards the writer
said after all hallmark has perfected
its tried-and-true formula generic cozy
formulaic over years it wouldn't be hard
to simply swap one gender in its pile of
unproduced scripts better yet solicit an
up-and-coming LGBTQ writer to craft the
script hire an LGBTQ director and cast
the movie with LGBTQ actors and etc and
so forth so what we see here once again
and this is related to you know what we
talked about the top of the show so it's
all part of the same theme what we see
once again is that all the stuff we
heard from the left four decades about
we're just trying to live our lives
leave us alone we'll leave you alone
live and let live right that was all a
big pile of BS as many people myself
included have been warning for years its
BS it's not true that's not their intent
never has been hallmark isn't hurting
anyone by making their corny movies the
way that they've been making them
doesn't hurt anybody
has anyone been actively hurt by the
fact that there isn't a gay character in
a hallmark movie
I mean hallmark is about the least
threatening company in existence you
don't get more harmless than hallmark
and the writer doesn't even seem to like
hallmark movies calls them formulaic
generic which they are of course so what
he's saying is you know these things are
bland and formulaic not very good but
just just put some gay actors and
characters in there anyway because I say
so
because it'd make me feel better it
would make me feel better to know that
you're following my ever my every demand
even if I don't watch the movie I just
want to know that you're doing what I
say and that's and that's what the LGBT
Lobby has been up to for years now and
that again is why their claims of it
doesn't affect you it doesn't it does
affect us you you want to affect us you
want to control what we say you want to
punish us for saying things you don't
like you want to indoctrinate our kids
into your belief system so I guess my
players at least be honest about it
be honest about what you're doing
especially with the the T on LGBT that
part of the lobby I mean this is the
most aggressive hostile lobby in the
country if you defy them they will try
to rip you to shreds and treat you like
scum look at what they're doing to JK
Rowling whose eye I read for you watch
that's all she said that's it she said
you know let's not fire women for saying
that sex is real and for that you should
see the things they're saying about this
woman and again you know yeah I know you
might not be sympathetic because she's
she's a left and she brought in to the
left as she brought this on herself and
I agree with that but still the
hostility the vitriol it's the attitude
is how dare you defy us even a little
bit how dare you think for yourself at
all you'll hear is your
find point of view and if you stray from
that even the slightest bit we will ruin
you and yet these people still want a
claim but no we're not trying to affect
you we're just trying a please please
just be honest that's all I'm asking
all right let's go to emails Matt Walsh
show at gmail.com Matt well show at
gmail.com this is from Henry says hi
Matt I completely agree with you about
expecting others to say Merry Christmas
and a set of Happy Holidays getting
triggered when a non-christian doesn't
say Merry Christmas is like saying he is
risen that Easter and getting upset when
a non-christian doesn't say risen indeed
yeah Henry I got a lot of emails on this
topic and several of them in
disagreement with us but my feeling is
all we did though the whole thing the
whole controversy about happy holidays
our Merry Christmas who cares who cares
makes no difference let people say what
they're comfortable with saying you know
trying to force people to say something
and especially just when someone is
trying to be friendly and they have no
ill intent to get offended by that to
complain about it if somebody says Happy
Holidays that's a friendly greeting
they're not trying to attack you it's
not it's not an attack on Christmas
they're trying to be nice so take it in
that spirit and move on with your life
and I think that's what most people do I
think on both sides I think there are
very few actually people on either side
who either get offended by Merry
Christmas or get offended by happy
holidays but there are some in there and
the problem is they're very loud all
right this is from Colin says Matt
exclamation point what are your top ten
movies of 2019 I don't think I I don't
think I've seen 10 movies in 2090 I
especially I especially have not seen 10
movies in 2019 that were released in
2019 so I can't really give a top 10 or
even a top 5 I will tell you I saw one
movie I saw in 2019 that I really liked
what was a ad astra the
the Brad Pitt space movie and I thought
it was a gorgeous film I thought it was
thought for thought I was interesting I
thought it was fundamentally about the
bond between a father and son or rather
I suppose about the sons longing for
that bond a law a longing that goes
frustrated frustrated ultimately but
it's really a beautiful and sad movie
and and I liked it a lot I thought ad
astra was basically what interstellar
wanted to be but wasn't let's see this
is from Taunus says hello Matt first
time sending you an email I'm a fan from
Thailand you said it doesn't have to be
Star Wars if you want to tell the story
about space and it doesn't have to be
spider-man or Iron Man if you want to
tell the story about someone with
supernatural powers I don't think that
was the only point why people want to
see them it's not just about space or
supernatural power stuff but also about
the characters growing that we grow to
love and after we see them within those
movies we want to see what's going on
with the Skywalker's in their space we
want to know what a Spider Man going
doing with his powers we want to know
what is going to happen in this new
movie that they are in I mean sure it
might be the same story again and again
we may like it or hate it but that
doesn't change the fact that we love to
see these characters in action kind of
like how we enjoy listening to your
speech again and again even though it's
the same stuff so is it really that bad
for us to get attached to those kind of
movies I'll wait to hear your answer
love your show
wow you do raise a good point me as
someone who tends about people repeat
myself constantly I guess I can't really
blame Star Wars for doing the same thing
but I'm first of all you know as I have
stated many times there is I have one
standard for myself and another another
standard for everybody else I've been
very clear about that so you know I can
do what I want but I expect other people
to be better than me I don't see the big
deal now I'm not saying it's bad to like
Star Wars in fact I said I totally
understand that people have a nostalgic
attachment
to the movie so you know that's that's
that's totally under that's
understandable to me if you grew up with
this movie you you you you you you have
that sort of relationship with the story
and with the film and I don't begrudge
that at all what I'm talking about is
just the actual quality of the movie I'm
saying that the Star Wars movies
generally have below average acting the
scripts are below average the stories
are repetitive and and that's it and so
maybe it's time to move on right it's
it's not like this is a story or the the
original trilogy was of such a nature
that it was just so incredible so deep
so rich that there is that it's a
never-ending source of additional
stories because obviously it's not they
the well has run dry and so let's move
on and tell other stories in space so
what's wrong with here's what I would
like to see Adam you have filmmakers
this generation of filmmakers who grew
up with stall star wars love the movie
have it have been influenced by it great
so what I would love to see is is for
them to go and make a different space
movie that's not a Star Wars movie but
that is influenced by it so whatever
happened to that see that I think that's
the way it's supposed to go it's not
it's not supposed to be oh I was
influenced by Star Wars so I'm gonna
make my own Star Wars no no just you're
influenced by it's one of the influences
you had as a filmmaker along with other
and go and so go and tell space movie
that yeah is reminiscent of Star Wars in
some ways but it's also a completely
different story it's like if you're a
filmmaker coming up and you loved The
Godfather as a you know when you were
younger you're very influenced by
Francis Ford Coppola and the Godfather
you're not gonna go and try to make
Godfather for you you know you might
tell have a mob movie that is
reminiscent in some ways of the
Godfather but it's it's still its own
thing so that that's what I'm saying
you had who is the guy the director that
made the last Rianne Johnson I he did I
think it was I don't know I think it was
the last not this latest in entry but
the one before that
well he's this is the same guy who did
looper which I thought was a very
interesting in good movie he did a movie
called brick link was his first movie
came out years ago in low-budget kind of
indie movie with Joseph gordon-levitt
also a really interesting movie I would
have loved to see that filmmaker who I
think is a very good filmmaker I would
have loved to see him tell a sci-fi
space movie not a Star Wars one not one
that has to fit into that cookie cutter
mold but I would love to see a guy with
those talents and that perspective
influenced by Star Wars and other films
tell his own space movie that would've
been great instead he told a Star Wars
movie you know he made a Star Wars movie
he told a Star Wars story and it was you
know it was kind of a bland middling
let's see all right moving on this is
from Jacob says hey Matt I listened to
your show daily came for Ben my
subscription isn't up yet so I can't say
stayed format but it makes you if it
makes you feel better sure it does make
me feel better I'm a 24 year old
Orthodox Jew as such I take off 10%
after-tax income for charity
a guy my age I haven't seen in years
messaged me asking how I was obviously
he wanted something so I asked what's up
he tell me his dad has two had two
strokes and he had to move in with him
bla bla can I help
I like how you just blah blah Dover dad
had two strokes
I felt bad and figured even if it was
bull the guy obviously needs help so I
sent him sent him 150 bucks he was over
the moon thanked me a thousand times
okay goodnight next day he tells me that
he thinks the reason his life is going
so bad is because he isn't religious can
I give him money to get food for Shabbat
I thought about it I want him to keep
Shabbat but I don't know I don't want to
now be his wallet I'm intern I'm
interning with barely and income myself
so I sent him another 70 do you think
the second installment was immoral also
creating an issue for myself
okay yes to the second question no to
the version wasn't immoral yeah you're
you're obviously very nice charitable
guy so you didn't do anything morally
wrong did you create an issue for
yourself yes because this person that
you're dealing with is what is known as
a leech and so I would cut him off
immediately I mean the very idea that
you're gonna ask somebody for money but
you haven't talked to in years and you
reach out to them and almost immediately
asking them for money okay well I think
this was your thought it's like Mel
that's definitely tacky but maybe he's
in dire straits he needs to reach out to
somebody doesn't know anybody else he's
reaching out to me so I'll help him out
I think I was I think I was very
generous of you he comes back the next
day it is asking for more money and the
setup for it is that he wants to be
religious and he needs a money to do it
what is this guy televangelist no I I
would I wouldn't give him another
freaking dime okay so I think you've
done your part this is from Michael says
last year you mentioned that it's a
wonderful life was one of your favorite
Christmas movies the film was considered
communist propaganda by many people when
it first released in 1947 I have had a
very long argument with my liberal
parents over the holidays about how the
movie was full of socialist tropes my
argument it by the way sound like my
sounds like my family at the holidays
not that anyone's liberal because we're
all crazy right-wingers but having a
long intense argument about something
like whether it's a wonderful life as a
communist movie I think that's great you
know I think I probably enjoy hanging
out with your family because there are
the families that can have arguments
like that they get very intense and go
on for hours and then there are the
families that can't and I'm definitely
in the canned category my argument was
that George Bailey was essentially
giving out subprime loans during the
Depression to people who could not
afford them while this disregarding his
fiduciary responsibilities to maximize
profit Potter who is the stockholder
Potter's then portrayed as an evil
greedy capitalist throughout the film
for being solvent during the Depression
and supplying free market housing for a
competitive price I would like to hear
you analyze this with your sound
reasoning since socialist ideology is
now so prevalent in this day and age and
old rich white men are
castigated in the worst possible light I
asked this question every year to the
Daily wire team and have yet to receive
an answer so I could hope that you can
fit it in your final email segment
before the years over while the topic is
still relevant well Michael I don't
disagree with what you're saying but
listen you could make the argument that
Santa Claus himself is a manipulative
nanny-state tyrant he watches you
watches you even while you're sleeping
think about creepy that is think about
the lyrics of that song he knows when
you're sleeping he knows when you're
awake my god he knows if you've been bad
or good then he breaks into your home he
rewards you if you comply with his
demands and if not he leaves a
terrifying threat in the form of a chunk
of coal a black coal now if you want to
be all literal about it you could say
that Santa is a morbidly obese big
brother figure who violates our privacy
rights violates our property rights and
violates our free speech rights and that
would all be true but it's Christmas so
we make an exception all I'm saying is
Santa gets off the hook in the spirit of
Christmas and it's in that same spirit
that I let George Bailey off the hook
even though he is a deadbeat
self-pitying whiner but but yeah alright
so I really don't have a response for
you I'm afraid it's it's I understand
what you're saying you're not wrong but
but still that's what that's the answer
I'm gonna give you I'm gonna give you a
yeah but still on that one this is from
LJ says hey Matt can you give us a great
recipe for bourbon eggnog I sure can LJ
what you do is well I tell you the
step-by-step present what you want to do
is take some bourbon out of your liquor
cabinet you want to pour a generous
portion of it into a glass and the next
step is drink the Bourbon the end
because obviously the last thing you
should ever do with the glory
elixir known as bourbon is mix it with
raw eggs for God's sake
that's my bourbon recipe hope you enjoy
it I know I'll be enjoying that form of
eggnog myself over the holidays and hope
all of you have great blessed Christmas
a Happy New Year I'll talk to you next
year
Godspeed Merry Christmas the Matt Walsh
show is produced by Sean Hampton
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Sterling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Mike Cora Mena the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
Ben Shapiro show we will get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there